foreign
to the beginning of work a complete
Construction
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
there are two basic conditions that make
rat life possible
one is the availability of food
the other is the availability of
harborage
the rat always tries to find a nesting
place close to its food supply
the rat tends to confine its movements
to a limited home range around the
feeding and harborage areas
cutting off the food supply reduces the
rat population
since rats must spend more and more of
their time searching their home range
for food
and even extending their search to
adjoining areas
when Food Supplies are restricted
Fierce competition develops for whatever
food can be found
in these struggles some rats are killed
the survivors then fight for the
opportunity to feed on the Dead
others abandon their customary home
range in a desperate search for new food
sources
in doing so they expose themselves to
increased risks and accidents
the mortality rate Rises considerably
when rats risk seeking food at sources
already controlled by other rat colonies
the Scavenging rat is often treated as
an enemy and driven off or killed
cleaning up rubbish and rat harborage
cuts down the rat population
routed from their nesting places many
rats are killed
rats that escape expose themselves in
unfamiliar territory
a rat deprived of its customary food or
harborage or of both has little chance
of survival
on the other hand killing rats without
disturbing their food or harborage
merely lessens competition
within a short time the rat population
will reach its previous proportions
control of the Rat therefore can be
permanent only if based on the removal
of the two fundamentals of rat life
food and harborage
rats can only be eliminated permanently
by thorough Sanitation
sanitation involves Good Housekeeping
outside premises as well as inside
the first step in a sanitation program
is an attack on garbage and litter
such refuse and litter must be cleaned
up
to do so deprives the rat of both food
and harborage
sanitation includes removal of bits of
food and nesting materials collected by
the rats
garbage cans should be made of heavy
gauge metal galvanized to prevent
rusting
the cover should be close fitting and
must be applied tightly so that rats and
domestic animals will be unable to
dislodge them
a wide rim should protect the bottom
the bottom should be made of double
thickness
the can should be placed on a concrete
slab at least four inches thick
such cans make garbage inaccessible to
rats they are an excellent step along
the road to rat control
sanitation if it were complete enough
might by itself achieve rat control
the nearer this goal is approached the
more effective is the control
storage of garbage is a necessary part
of Community Living
yet this important function is usually
neglected
open garbage containers found almost
everywhere provide the rat's basic needs
for existence
where a considerable quantity of garbage
must be stored a rat proof garbage house
should be provided
it should be of the walk-in type and
must be both rat proof and fly proof
the door should be self-closing the
garbage cans should be rat proof with
tight fitting covers
frequent and regular washing will keep
the garbage house clean and free from
unpleasant odors
an adequate garbage house properly
serviced is an effective means of
reducing rat infestation
garbage houses may be inside as well as
outside buildings
shifting of garbage from one container
to another provides opportunities for
spillage
such spillage reduces the effects of
good storage and adds to the rat's food
supply
wherever possible garbage cans should be
carried directly to the garbage trucks
thus accidental spillage is avoided
garbage in transit or otherwise must be
made inaccessible to rats
the garbage truck therefore should be
spill proof and easy to load
where Modern garbage trucks are not
available a dump truck may be used
temporarily
however the truck should be watertight
with an incline at the rear to prevent
liquids from running out
a canvas cover should be used at all
times to protect full and partial loads
from spilling and being blown from the
truck
a device which eliminates the individual
garbage can as well as the need for
emptying it into a truck
is a gadget called a movable garbage
storage and carrier box
when properly located and intelligently
used it eliminates storage of garbage on
the premises as a source of rat food
at regularly scheduled intervals the
storage box is inspected
when full a specially designed truck
comes to pick it up
the box is hoisted onto the truck by a
hydraulic lift
the entire operation can be handled if
necessary by one man
the truck then carries the box to the
garbage disposal site where it will be
emptied washed and treated with
deodorant and insecticide before being
returned to its original location on the
premises
but good storage and transportation
practices are ineffective unless
followed by proper garbage disposal
for instance garbage dumping on Hog
Farms provides ideal conditions for rat
life and create serious health hazards
unloading of garbage into open city
dumps is an insanitary practice and
supports a large rat population
such practices are not compatible with
modern ideas of Sanitation
and must be eliminated
an efficient means of garbage disposal
is the sanitary landfill
for one thing it requires a minimum
capital investment
also it allows the use of wasteland
located close to the center of the
collection area
thus cutting down time lost in hauling
in one type of sanitary landfill the
garbage is spread in thin layers in a
trench and compacted
this compaction destroys any rats and
rat harborages that may be present
a two foot layer of Earth over the
compacted garbage eliminates the
possibility of later rat infestation the
in addition the Earth covering does away
with fly breeding and reduces the
possibility of spontaneous combustion
and insanitary and unsightly dump can be
turned into a helpful and useful area
another method of garbage disposal is by
incineration
for large communities an incineration
plant can be built which requires no
separation of combustible and
non-combustible matter
in one of the recommended systems the
refuse is fed into a drying crate
and proceeds from there through a
burning kiln
and to a rotating kill the rotating Kiln
continually shifts the burning material
so that all food and combustible wastes
are consumed
this prolongs drying and burning process
practically eliminates the need for
auxiliary fuel
some incinerators particularly those in
small communities are not satisfactory
because of incomplete combustion of
garbage
frequently such incinerators are
designed to process combustible wastes
only
thus requiring prior separation of
combustible from non-combustible refuse
since the refuse is not dried in advance
or agitated in burning auxiliary fuel is
often necessary
the cost of fuel plus higher labor
charges makes this type of incineration
more expensive than the sanitary
landfill
also partially charred garbage taken
from the incinerator and dumped on open
ground will support a large rat
population
furthermore the non-combustible waste
must still be disposed of or it may
become a harborage for rats
therefore even with an incinerator the
sanitary landfill is necessary
another method of garbage disposal is by
grinding as with a home grinding unit
most grinding units will accept
practically anything but such substances
as metal China and glass
these non-grindable wastes must be
stored adequately until they are
disposed of preferably by the sanitary
landfill method
with grinding units grindable wastes are
converted to a mesh and are discharged
directly into the sewers
the important contribution of this
method is that it eliminates storage and
transport of discarded food
but regardless what method is used the
fundamental principle is to make garbage
and rubbish unavailable to rats
sanitation requires Good Housekeeping
outside and inside premises
this applies to the home as well as to
business establishments
in the Home Food Products must be
guarded carefully
even water is an unnecessary concession
to rat convenience
kitchen carelessness is an open
invitation to rats to help themselves to
our groceries
cereals are a favorite rat food
storage of cereals in Rat proof or rat
repellent containers provides permanent
protection against rats
these and similar procedures of food
storage are based on making food
inaccessible to rats
objects of sentimental value can
accumulate in attics where the rats find
the rubbish to be excellent harborage
the best thing to do is to clean out the
attic thus getting rid of the rats and a
fire hazard as well
in commercial establishments large and
small
poor housekeeping provides unlimited
food and perfect harborage for rats
Good Housekeeping in food storage places
is a safeguard against rat infestation
the merchandise should be neatly stacked
on racks away from the walls
two foot aisles about every four feet
permit ready inspection and cleanup
an 18 inch space under the racks permits
easy cleaning of the floors
under these conditions rat feces and
signs of rat habitation can easily be
detected and rat eradication
accomplished quickly
proper stacking constant inspection and
efficient maintenance are necessary
steps in good premise housekeeping
but the effects of Good Housekeeping can
be nullified if any space such as a
Cellar is left untidy and cluttered with
rubbish
such places should be cleaned up
if any of the materials are needed they
should be properly stacked
everything of no value should be removed
and destroyed
but here is a modern office building
with no food storage at all
yet there are rats
how can they live here
the answer is simple
again thoughtlessness and lack of
Sanitation have provided them with the
essential of life
this is the answer
a rat proof disposal can for all
lunchtime food scraps
both by guarding food and by disposing
of wastes good sanitation procedures
Force rats to leave their home ranges
and to face the Perils of an unfamiliar
environment
[Music]
on the other hand wherever food is kept
there is always a likelihood of rat
infestation
to supplement and reinforce good
sanitation measures a technique has been
developed the purpose of which is to
block off all passages by which rats
might gain entry to a building
therefore in addition to depriving the
rat of food and harborage
one must also employ the techniques of
rat proofing
thank you